all right let's jump right into what's
going on the difference between
millennials and gen z now if you don't
know about millennials
millennials
basically born 1980 1981 until about the
mid-90s okay 95-96 the generation right
after that that's gen z
all right otherwise known as the i gen i
with an i dot because they were born
with iphones in their hands basically so
the igen right
um
they were born mid to late 90s 96 97 up
until about uh 2010 so just to give it
to age of perspective millennials are
basically the oldest of them are about
40 right now uh they're about hitting 40
and they go into about mid 20s and then
gen z they're in their mid-20s all the
way down to i don't know
elementary yeah sixth grade basically 10
12 years old so that's it the generation
after that is generation alpha my nephew
eight years old generation alpha because
it goes
x gen x
gen y millennials
gen z
remix start all over now you're at gen a
gen alpha and alpha yeah so it all
starts over again jenna alpha gen a not
that we're gonna spend a lot of time on
that because they're not working yet not
even in middle school yet
um
first generation that every single
person in that generation was born
after the millennium
so everyone in the millennials they were
called millennials because they came to
age during 2000. they might have been in
high school they might have been in
middle school but they were coming of
age around 2000. that's falling off yeah
gen z
they were born
some before 2000 some after two thousand
like you were born in what 95 95 all
right so close to 2 000 cusp
cusp there it is great word gen alpha
everyone was born after 2000 and
specifically about 2010 anyway so what
are the key differences in these two
major generations
um let's get into them there's five
major differences this is an article
from the list and we've got five
parts of this list let's do it let's do
it all right so let's pull this up so
number one this breaks my heart to even
say it breaks my heart number one
millennials may be more indulgent a.k.a
they like to spend that money aka
indulge so millennials likely grew up
with a with more privilege
due to not due to having being raised at
a time when the economy was chugging
right along they grew up in the 90s
that's where i grew up in the 90s and
the economy was booming fresh prince of
bel-air was out there people bill
clinton's in office what was better the
peace the prosperity both the 90s were
rocking and rolling whereas
gen z many of them were basically born
right
around
um
right before the uh
2001
dot com
bust right and then right before the
great recession of 2008 so they just
basically they got smack dab they're
dealing with bad economies that's gen z
so their parents were like chill
chill we just went through a couple
serious stuff yeah right dot com boom uh
bust
and uh 2008 great recession
still save your money don't expect to be
balling so that's number one millennials
raised in the 90s expected to have a
good time
um they were raised on boiler room wolf
of wall street type of mentality
literally the movie wall street whereas
gen z they had a little rougher go of it
so that's number one millennials may be
more indulgent aka like to spend that
money yeah part of the reason i started
the show i started what millennials were
doing i was like
oh you guys got it all wrong no and
we've seen a lot of that in a lot of the
rolling loud and stuff that we've gone
to gen z is very like
shockingly shockingly they they maybe
they don't look the part yeah because
they're young maybe they're 21 they
don't look the part but wow we got some
good answers from rolling out save that
money yeah we'll touch on that for sure
all right number two gen z plans to do
whatever it takes to get ahead
so this again according to according to
the list one report revealed that jen's
ears who are basically aged 18 to 20 to
24
right around now they listed money
and money making as their main life goal
main life goal make that money
reports state that 70 percent of gen
zier's their number one goal was to make
money whereas only 60 percent of
millennials prioritized making money so
basically millennials were
are more
what's that dreamers whatever more they
just want to be happy man i just want to
be happy
gen z they just want a ferrari yeah
that's sort of the difference right
there so anyway that's number two
millennials a little more
want to be happiness purpose driven gen
z
go ahead and make that money number
three gen z prefers to save
rather than spend you know that makes me
feel good like we talked about we went
to rolling loud and see what these kids
are we were shocked at how smart they
were shocked
18 21 year old kids shocked drunk too
explaining all these things that they
were drunk as hell invested in the game
what about the one kid that we
interviewed on the fort lauderdale beach
about oh my god really impressive you
would never expect of him either let me
tell you something
i'm not going to be that i'm 40. i'm not
going to be that old guy that's like
these kids these days they don't know i
think i'm really impressed with these
young generation super impressed yeah
and respect to you jen's
consistent it's not even like a one-off
oh that one time and it's like every
time we talk
aside from some of the face tats that
some of these young kids are trending
towards yeah they're on the ball on the
ball they're on the ball all right
um
so they they they here's a little they
cite a little example right here they
hand a hundred bucks to a millennial and
they hand another hundred bucks to a gen
z kid oh boy the millennial is more
likely to blow it all in a nice meal
with a friend
whereas a member of gen z may be more
apt to deposit that money in the bank
or throw into their coin boys coinbase
account and invest in crypto a couple
differences right there so
i think with you know the advent and the
um
the relevance of
investment apps which we'll touch on in
this show
gen z's can just make these money moves
make all these sorts of investments and
they're used to these kind of things
whereas millennials didn't have that
sort of inherent built in to what they
got going on yeah so again
gen z prefers to save whereas
millennials prefer to spend now this is
a generalization obviously you know they
said sixty percent of
millennials
are prior to
prioritize money whereas 70 percent of
gen z not a crazy difference but you
know law of large numbers um number four
gen z
is wary of student loans this is
something they have learned from their
older brothers sisters uncles whatever
that student loans
that [ __ ] will get you so here's the
here's the example why sync yourself
into exorbitant amounts of debt when you
can learn everything online or learn a
specific subject matter at a fraction of
the price right yeah so gen z is
thinking why spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars on college and student loans
when you can learn everything on youtube
for free 99.
great bargain i'm not wrong right so gen
z is basically you know they've got gary
vee
you know shouting on him don't go to
college just
go to garage sales and sell your stuff
and hustle and make money whereas like
millennials they kind of got tony
robbins that's like just be happy you
know fulfill your purpose in life it's
kind of different yeah different mentors
right obviously pbd over here is a huge
advocate of not necessarily going to
college
and um
becoming an entrepreneur that's
obviously what this channel's about
bottom line is millennials will want a
little bit more of a happiness where gen
z wants some zeros in the bank account
okay
last point and we'll open this up for
discussion zen z is having is giving
advertisers
headaches let's explain what that means
unfortunately for the advertisers of
today gen z is anything
but loyal
in their shopping habits this generation
has been shopping online ever since they
were old enough to navigate the touch
screen we all know that shopping online
online means you can browse from site to
site in search of the lowest prices
best sales
and free shipping that's just you know
obviously that comes with that so
basically
take away with that
these gen z kids they don't have zero
brand loyalty loyalty they don't give a
[ __ ]
okay they're basically saying all right
i can go to this i can buy this online
for uh 52. or i can get this for uh 49
i'm gonna do the 49 i don't give a [ __ ]
what the brand is like i'm gonna take
the cheaper price that's just an example
you know let's say it's a pair of shoes
that's what they would do so the zero
brand loyalty apparently
as much
with the gen z other than maybe if it's
supreme um yeah yeah like a big trending
thing right right anyway so that that
that just to wrap it up a nutshell
millennials may
spend more
gen z will do quote unquote whatever it
takes to get ahead gen z prefers to save
more gen z is wary of student loans i
understand that and gen z is less brand
loyal david yeah yeah and basically a
little uh little recap there's basically
the 2008 recession
um
separated the older millennials from the
younger millennials 2008 recession
because it was the older millennials
that basically were already in the
workforce they already graduated school
whatever they're already working they
had jobs they had some skills right they
had some hard skills that they learned
on the job whereas younger millennials
maybe they were in college at that time
high school at that time
the job market
crashed for at least two three years
so they had to basically pay the price
of not you know graduating into a shitty
economy not getting a job so there's an
older generation of millennials and a
younger generation of millennials just
to put in perspective
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken